foreign
and I took a call from a young Widow
last week in her 30s her husband had
died in a construction accident and she
was her home was in foreclosure and she
was in tears through the whole call and
it has tugged at the heartstrings of
everyone who's listened to that call
John and me included and um
uh I had if you have heard that or or
yet to hear it but you'll hear that I
explained to her she's not going to lose
the house and that we're going to get uh
Lisa our senior uh financial counselor
that works with crisis stuff on on the
job here and furnish it to her take care
of her because as uh people of the
Christian faith were instructed by our
book to take care of widows and orphans
and so we do that's simple and so we
took care of her uh Lisa's met with her
she's got all kinds you know the chaos
that was all over her life is starting
to come into order of the house will of
course not be foreclosed on she had a
sixty thousand dollar mortgage on 375
000 house we're not losing that house
boys and girls okay so uh not happening
so anyway we didn't lose the house
everything's gonna be fine there's a lot
of details to be buttoned up but just an
update that uh she's fine she's fine and
literally thousands of you have reached
out to us to offer assistance to her
Finance and so forth on the different
social media platforms thank you for
that number one we have no way of
organizing all of that stuff we don't
run a Telethon and so there's no
possible logistical way we could number
two she doesn't need it she's under
control we got we got her yeah you know
a couple people stepped up in the
community uh the church you know hooking
her up with the church it's going to
help her we've got Lisa who's got
superpowers when it comes to negotiating
with foreclosures and dealing with
mortgage companies and she has all of
the regulatory knowledge that strikes
fear Into the Heart of collectors and so
all of that so we got we got it we got
it she's in good shape thank you guys
but let me just tell you the thing I
want to bring up was thank you a for all
of you that reached out and those of you
that even thought gosh I wish I could
help her yeah you know here's what we've
always done in 30 years of doing the
show because sometimes one of these
things elicits this kind of a response
from our wonderful audience because we
got great people in our eyes absolutely
is hey what that means is God is telling
you to help
not her but somebody else there's plenty
of folk right there within reach of you
whoever you are that need help there's
plenty of folk that two thousand dollars
have changed their life okay a thousand
dollar car for a single mom in that
situation and change your life yeah and
ten thousand dollars to do it for ten of
them so this is why you get out of debt
this is why you live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else so what I'm asking you to do in
this particular case is take the
function take the uh the spiritual
Direction you feel inside of you to help
and go help yeah you're not gonna help
this particular lady but there's one
just like her down the block I promise
you they're all over the world and so uh
help that's what it's for because here's
the thing if we the people take care of
we the people we can make the government
as irrelevant as it actually is
you can put them out of business I know
that drop that put them out of the
helping people business that would
um alleviate a lot of Heartache a lot of
pain a lot of taxes yeah it would
alleviate a lot of stupidity and it
would take the power from politicians to
buy your vote that's a good word so we
the people taking care of We the People
is how it's supposed to be done it's
called Community it's called connection
and uh it's called generosity it's a
good muscle for everyone to flex every
so often and um inviting you guys to do
just that and again thank you for your
response to that lady that was a
heart-wrenching call and situation it
really was and hopefully for the
listeners it shows you know we talk all
the time Dave this is a community we're
not just people telling you get out of
debt get there are Facebook communities
there are people doing this with you and
they truly care about your journey
they're right there with you and if that
doesn't show it I don't know what it
does 500
000 people on the baby steps Facebook
page yeah I mean the baby's Facebook
Community yeah you want to get some
advice they won't tear you up in there
they will tear you up but they don't
think I'm tough you think I'm tough jump
your butt in that Community yeah but I
mean yeah there's you're right there's a
lot of interaction going on amongst uh
you guys our tribe us uh this is not
simply us barking at you on one end of a
microphone and you on the speaker end on
the other side there's a lot going on
here and this kind of a thing
illustrates that it does it does there's
there's people out there rooting for you
they've been there they know how it
feels and the chance that they get to
jump in and hope they're going to take
that chance well that's how you ended up
you know you and Sam ended up becoming
Financial Peace University coordinators
heck yeah you don't go through this and
not want to help somebody on the other
side of it because it changes your lens
now when you walk out you notice the
person behind you in the checkout you
know what I'm saying you notice you
start to notice things that you've never
noticed before and you know you see that
person taking out their phone and
checking their account before they pay
you see that stuff now and so yeah you
got to go back and help pay it forward
once you're aware you can't be unaware
that's right you know it does open up
your eyes and get things moving so guys
jump in and do that just find somebody
to be a blessing to uh the odd thing is
is that it'll bless you the odd thing is
is that generosity actually does this
much or more for the giver than it does
the receiver and it seems like Jesus
talked about that so there you go uh the
The Giver is more blessed you know is
what it amounts to and so it's good it's
a good it's a good exercise it's a good
reminder for all of us that this is
where help comes from
God does not use governments God uses
people to help people
it's his preferred tool
so keep that in mind next time someone
wants to announce a new program